pour moi c'est une entrée qui à côté de
la plaque si on n'avait pas de la
couleur on aurait pensé que c'est une
une déclaration des années 50
je trouve que c'est d'une arrogance
extraordinaire
jamais oublier que j'ai eue avant de
venir à l'émission j'ai eu quelqu'un qui
était dans la campagne d'eric zemmour et
qu'il a quitté au moment des
commémorations du 13 novembre des
attentes avec shakuri talent d'or le
bataclan si tu cherchais quelqu'un qui
veut qu'il veut être anonyme et que j'ai
appelé parce que je lui dirai se
croit-il est ce que est ce que vous
étiez est ce que vous étiez au courant
que vous pouviez être attaqué par
rapport aux images la personne me dit
c'est de l'amateurisme total et depuis
le départ il m'a dit on fait les choses
dans l'improvisation la plus totale et
la personne est partie à la quitter la
campagne parce que devant le matin il
trouvait que c'était indigne d'avoir
fait ce qu'il a fait on a vu qu'à
marseille il n'a pas pu rencontrer est
marseillais deuxième ville de france
quand même je veux dire à un moment non
sentir maxi militant je sais pas de fait
ça par bwin depuis quelques semaines
quand parise est mort et sa déclaration
de quelle nature à mon avis démontre
qu'il est dans il est dans un temps qui
n'est pas le nôtre celui du 21e siècle
et sa conception de la france est
passéiste et nostalgique elles mêmes
fantasmes et la phrase dont nous parle
des mots il n'existe mais si c'était pas
grave c'est une vision raciste et
xénophobe c'est ça qui est actuellement
inquiétant que c'est une vision qui sait
que cette affaire président et non qu'on
n'a pas dire merci
j'ai pas évoquer les questions sur ma
présence dans l'équipe et moi j'ai moi
je m'en fous en revanche je me mets à la
place de certaines personnalités qui ont
été convoqués par zemmour dans cette
vidéo comme incarnant la france dont il
rêve et qui ne veulent pas du tout de
voir associer à lui la part entière ne
venant pas moi qui a fait naître pour se
dissocier totalement ça comment il peut
citer quelqu'un comme brassens brassens
qui aurait owni un personnage monde on
commence comme zemmour d'amour donc il
va être attaquée de toute part en part
mentionné qu'ils ont droit de cité des
gens invoqué des gens
comme les autres vous ne devez pas les
autres c'est dingue de schiste ce n'est
pas une pensée politique anodine alors
n'est pas un candidat comme léonard est
et nous faire croire ça mais vous pouvez
nous les volets sur les plateaux de ciné
vous voulez mais c'est tout le match
sont des quinze nouvelles chansons les
plateaux voulait empêcher les mom and
image d idée d'eric zemmour il
rassure c'est quelqu'un me aux familles
ne fait que son goût de promouvoir la
haine mais non il ya pas mal alors
je pense qu'on doit réussir son entrée
en campagne la nasse et aymeric caron
qui a réussi son numéro très beau numéro
de bien pensants
[Applaudissements]
on attend votre mère vous venez
complètement de faire tomber votre
masque vous n'avez aucun respect envers
les autres vous n'avez aucun respect
pour ceux qui pensent différemment
d'obliger le plus gros qu'elle fait pour
vous je vous aucun nous empoisonner
faire l'âne est venu vérifier répondre
je vous autorise à être en désaccord en
revanche je faisais pas vrai de mais
merci vous m'autorisez encore tandis que
les démos et lui faire dire c'est vous
la qui dit non au fascisme oui moi je
dit penser différemment ce vote blanc
voulait dire que parce que j'avais des
noms de la bonne opposition
laissez-nous nous ait lui même vous
exprimez beaucoup beaucoup à dire et à
dire noir aujourd'hui ils représentent
des idées qui sont majoritaires en
france il ya eu un sondage dans sa
majorité à jour facilement c'est soit
majoritairement raciste et xénophobe